opinions expressed on this program are
those of the guests appearing on the
program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
we have hope now a vaccine is coming
within weeks
tonight on politics now looking for a
light at the end of the tunnel
the new timeline for a covid 19 vaccine
and who gets it first
our election is now official the change
of course from clark county in a race
decided by just 10 votes
plus i'm alexandra limon in washington
where lawmakers continue to be stalled
over a new coronavirus relief package
and one senator warns the worst of the
pandemic
could still be ahead of us
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
while nevada faces more covet 19 cases
there is
hope on the horizon thank you for
joining us here on politics now i'm john
langler
governor steve sisilak says he hopes to
have the first round of vaccination
doses available
here by the middle of december the state
will give frontline healthcare workers
the first
possible doses and then nursing home
workers vaccines are scheduled to be
available to the public by the spring or
summer of 2021.
governor sissellac and his team say
medicine for moderna and pfizer are
about 95 percent effective
we have hope now a vaccine is coming
within weeks we will begin distributing
and giving people needle sticks i mean
that's a positive thing this has been
done in record time
and it's our hope that we can get as
much of this as we can out in the
general public
we'll build more and more immunity and
we can start to get back to our regular
lives
the vaccine will be administered in two
doses and the first available again
this month the time in between doses
will be
either 21 or 28 days however coronavirus
has obviously devastated nevada's
economy
new details from the legislative
economic forum show just how much damage
has been done
since june the state's total gaming
revenue is down
27.2 percent that's 1.4 billion dollars
in this graph analysts project a gradual
recovery over the next few years
nevada's gaming control board projects
8.7 billion dollars in revenue for the
next fiscal year
that's a drop of 11.2 percent locals
tend to drive the slot machine numbers
it's table games like blackjack that are
more dependent on international visitors
many resorts on the strip have closed
hotel operations during the slow
mid-week days
we're having a slow period on top of the
fact we don't have any events that
pump up the business during that time
period nfr is gone
um for this year new year's i can't
imagine our new year's is going to be
anywhere near what we've experienced in
the past
and then uh january the large the large
conventions the the ces that's not
happening so
i think it's going to be a challenging
couple months
[Music]
the live entertainment tax took the
biggest hit here in nevada more than 99
there were no shows analysts say the
vaccine announcement though
is good news for their projections of
the economy moving forward
another thing that would help in nevada
another coronavirus relief bill
however coronavirus cases are surging
nationwide
as alexander limon reports some
lawmakers say the relief
needs to come now
we're dealing with the corona virus
pandemic but they're also dealing with a
hunger pandemic and they have never
seen anything like this oregon senator
ron wyden says
americans will likely see both the
health and economic impacts of the
pandemic
get worse over the coming months a
tsunami
of evictions people losing their homes
that's why he and top democrats
introduced the american worker holiday
relief
act which allows americans to qualify
for 26
additional weeks of unemployment
benefits and extends the 600
a week federal boost through october of
2021.
it also ensures freelance and gig
economy workers qualify for extended
benefits
for months lawmakers have failed to
reach an agreement on a new coveted
relief package
in part because they can't agree on
whether to extend the
extra 600 a week in unemployment
benefits
larry kudlow director of the national
economic council says
the white house isn't against extending
unemployment benefits
but he suggests paying for it with the
hundreds of billions of dollars that are
left over from previous relief packages
repurpose it back to the ppps the
unemployment assistance
school covid related k-12 assistance
there's some airlines democrats say the
cost of the long-term economic relief
that's needed
will surpasses the amount of money
that's left over
in washington alexandra limon
joining us now are washington d.c bureau
reporter alexander limon to talk about
covid 19 relief
it does appear alex there is some
momentum on capitol hill for a
compromise on some sort of a package
what are the details and is it likely to
pass
that's right and this bill comes from a
group of lawmakers that call themselves
the
problem solvers caucus they are a group
of democrats and republicans that strive
to come up with
bipartisan pieces of legislation and in
this case they've come up with a
900 billion dollar coveted relief bill
that they say
is a really good compromise between
democrats and republicans
some of the things that it offers is
more help for small businesses via the
paycheck protection program
also some money for state and local
governments for
airlines and also money for covid
testing
and for a vaccine distribution program
what it does not include is another
round of those
direct stimulus check payments to
americans
it does however include more money for
extended
unemployment insurance and this is where
the compromise part comes in
it includes 300 additional unemployment
insurance
a week for 18 weeks you may remember
democrats were really set on that 600
a week number and they wanted it for at
least 26 more weeks so that's where
they're compromising and it also
includes protections
uh for for businesses from covid related
lawsuits again this is something
democrats that were
set against that they're saying we are
willing to consider
this in order to get something done on
covet relief
let's say lawmakers do reach an
agreement on capitol hill how quickly
could it actually get passed and made
into reality well it really depends on
whether they can reach an
agreement you know senator mitch
mcconnell has said he will not call a
bill to the floor unless he thinks that
thinks that president trump would sign
it but that's really interesting because
it's different messaging than what we're
hearing from white house officials like
larry kudlow and steven mnuchin for
example they've actually seemed
more supportive of this compromise bill
and said that the president would sign
it if mitch mcconnell supported it so
if they can reach some sort of a
compromise bill
it's very likely that they would attach
it to the budget bill that they're
trying to work on
they have to get that passed by december
11 in order to try to
avoid a government shutdown so it's very
likely that a covet bill
could be attached to that in order to
get it passed you know within the next
few days
that is alexander limon from washington
with her dog for the i-team's david
charns asked nevada democratic senator
catherine cortez-masto about the
potential for a relief
bill and her new leadership position as
the vice chair of
outreach is this an
issue in terms of senate leadership
that's holding this whole thing up
or is this something else i mean you're
you're in
you're in there on the on the floor in
the chamber so what are your
what are you seeing so how the rules
work in the senate who's ever in control
whoever the majority leader of the
senate controls what goes on the floor
of the senate for votes
whether whatever legislation whether
there can be amendments whether there
can be debates
right now mitch mcconnell is control of
of
the senate so he has controlled what
goes on to the floor and he has refused
to bring forward
the house bills that have already passed
to bring additional relief
into um our communities and so
many of us not just democratic senators
but some of my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle have been demanding
that we have support bipartisan support
negotiations around another package for
relief because
it is so needed in our communities it
should have been done months ago
listen i was just home last week
i went to a mobile food site that three
square has put together there were over
350 cars
in line and they started lining up at
3am there was so much food insecurity
because our economy in nevada has been
devastated by this pandemic so more
relief yes is needed and so that's why i
support this bipartisan proposal
it gets additional relief into our
communities
in the next four months that's necessary
right now
congratulations on your new leadership
position
with the democratic party moving into
the next congress
do you plan to do anything or or does
that give us
or does that give you know nevada a
little bit of a leg up in any way in
terms of what comes across
uh at the senate yes it does and that's
why i was honored to be in leadership
because my focus is
nevada first and foremost always and now
in a leadership
position i could use my voice from
nevada to advocate for nevadans
and so yes that's number one number two
um
with the transition that we have with
the new administration
i'm already engaging in conversations
with the transition team
and and moving into how we create a
long-term
infrastructure to continue to
communicate with the next
administration for needs that we have in
nevada
and so this is something that i intend
to capitalize on not only the leadership
position
but my opportunity to really build a
relationship with the new administration
to focus on the needs of nevadans
we have that entire interview available
for you over at eight newsnow dot com
just look for the politics now tab
coming up here on politics now ccsd
reverses course
it's a a policy that you can barely read
four sentences without hitting something
that it gets wrong
the school district's policy on
regulating free speech of employees and
the strong reaction against it
and we will have a recount the latest on
the clark county commission race
smith's fresh for everyone welcome back
to politics now
the closest race in our 2020 election is
now official
however there is going to be a recount
for now democrat ross miller will
fill the clark county commission's seat
c and that is
because he beat republican stavros
anthony by 10 votes
this week election officials in clark
county switched course and
certified the vote now at first they
asked for a re-vote because of the large
number of discrepancies it was larger
than the margin between the two
candidates of just 10 votes
discrepancies are things like when a
person signs in to vote but fails to
actually cast one
a judge ruled this week a re-vote
wouldn't necessarily change the results
so miller was certified as the winner
over 150 000 people voted in this
contest
it's very out of the ordinary for a a
race with that many votes to be decided
by
10. that margin of victory is very
difficult to reconcile no matter what
the race is with 215 precincts in it
on thursday anthony stavros-anthony said
he would ask for
a recount the election staff will start
working on that on monday and it should
be finished
finished by next friday also clark
county registrar joe gloria who you just
heard from
he says his office has received hundreds
of calls from people who received
false information about their vote not
being counted
now an update on the litigation filed by
republicans in the trump campaign here
in nevada
nevada republicans have now dropped
their federal lawsuit which claimed
widespread voter fraud
now you might remember that news
conference two days after the election
when republicans announced this law
this lawsuit it alleged roughly ten
thousand people cast ballots
even though they don't live in nevada
anymore they also claimed dead voters
had ballots cast in their names
a separate state lawsuit filed by the
trump campaign trying to stop the
electors from casting their votes for
joe biden
well that is still waiting for a ruling
those six democratic electors are
scheduled to cast their votes for
the president-elect joe biden on
december 14th
just before thanksgiving the clark
county school district posted a
controversial proposal
about redefining employee-free speech
but as soon as it went up on the
district district's website
well it was removed basically right
after the holiday kristen drummond shows
us the concerns from ccsd staff
and the legality of the measure we all
should be standing up
uncertainty and unease this is like the
worst
possible time for them to roll out
something like this
ccsd staff and parents questioned the
intention of a policy proposal removed
suddenly monday evening from the
district website
a two-page document titled employee
freedom of speech
these are screen shots of the regulation
that seems to impose restrictions on
when employees can talk freely about
public concerns
which includes district issues what was
the origin
of proposing a regulation like this we
believe that this
is someone in the district's attempt
to keep employees from
speaking up about important issues
troubling many
ccsd staff as well as free speech
attorney ari cones
it's a policy that you can barely read
four sentences without hitting something
that it gets wrong
he found the document and posted a
twitter thread calling it
a really bad policy drafting i think the
thing that struck me
is that it seemed to quote language that
sounded familiar
from the supreme court cases but the way
it did it
made you really wonder if the people
actually read the cases
the education support employees
association released a statement
it says in part the trustees should
withdraw this embarrassing and
unconstitutional proposal or they will
waste district dollars having a court do
it for them
the clark county education association
tells me the union has nothing to share
at this time
kristen drummond 8 news now
the aclu says it is analyzing the
documents still
and waiting to hear back from its own
free speech experts on a national level
coming up next on politics now reforming
metro police
and so officers are dealing with with
homeless people
people who are sleeping on uh bus stop
benches
and you're right um social workers
could fill that void
up next changes the police union says it
will talk about at the next legislative
session
plus who is going to lead some of the
key committees in carson city during the
upcoming session
news now you're watching
politics now
in november our i-team did a week-long
series on police reform and what has
changed here
in the last year some of that includes
hiring and firing practices and use of
force policies
now after that series our george knapp
interviewed former district attorney
and a current police union attorney doug
david roger i beg your pardon
we talked about what would happen in the
upcoming legislature
so much unrest over the summer so much
anger around the country
state legislatures city governments
we're looking at
a variety of police reform options the
nevada legislature
included you went to the legislature
to present some options from the ppa
what was the reception uh we got the
stiff arm from from the nevada
legislature you know
a year earlier the nevada legislature
passed a peace officer's bill of rights
these are procedural rights that
officers have during
internal investigations um
12 months later the nevada legislature
wiped all of that that out and you know
we felt
i felt that it was a knee jerk reaction
you know
um they had they had six months before
six
seven months before the 2021 legislature
there was time to for hearings and
discussion about the changes and uh they
wiped it out
in in a matter of two days and and i
felt that that was
uh unfair to the officers and very
unfortunate
just a reaction to the political
environment the pressure
you know what we found uh was that uh
this was a vocal minority that was
pushing
uh all of these changes and it was a
national
national discussion uh but you know i
i believe and there's some empirical
data that the people of clark county
uh believe in their police officers they
don't want to defund
the police officers and although
they may not agree with every um
every incident or every policy that the
sheriff enacts
they have a great deal of faith in in
their police department
and i i just thought that the
legislature
played to the vocal minority is there a
way forward where we can
de-escalate the involvement of officers
in certain situations
just mentally ill maybe redirect some
money
and that resolves a lot of these
concerns or
not well i i don't want to redirect the
sheriff's money because
he knows where where the money should be
spent
but you know we we have a homeless issue
in
in clark county officer
when there's a problem people call the
police because they don't know who else
to call
and so officers are dealing with with
homeless people
people who are sleeping on bus stop at
benches
and you're right social workers could
fill that void
are there any other reforms that you
your members your officers in ppa would
would uh support or have in mind
you know i i think that as an
organization uh
you know metro police officers are
always looking
at cutting edge uh policies and tactics
and
and training they love to train they
don't have enough time to to train
uh but they are always willing to
improve
what they some are not inclined to be
is the pinata to be beat on by the
legislature
when you know we are we've gotten the
stamp of approval from the department of
justice
you can watch the entire interview and
our series on police reform over at
eight newsnow dot com just look for the
politics now page
and the state of metro banner you'll get
the information you want to look for
coming up on politics now who will be in
charge of the committees in carson city
on those reform bills and who will have
to make it go through
[Music]
nevada republican congressman mark
ameday says he has expressed interest in
running for governor in 2022
i don't think it's news to anybody but
they think that governor sissel act
in some ways has made himself vulnerable
for reelection
i'm sure he doesn't agree with that and
i'm not going to be disrespectful
but it's like so so there's a lot of
people kicking tires right now
and we're certainly going to kick our
share of them here in the near future
amadeu made those comments during the
metro chamber of commerce eggs and
issues breakfast this week
amadeus holds the congressional district
2 seed up in northern nevada right now
other republicans whose names whose
names have been mentioned for a
potential gubernatorial run one of them
former senator dean heller we are only a
few months away from the 2021
legislative session in carson city
this week assembly committee assignments
were announced so let's take a look at
them
and of course with democrats in control
they're going to chair all of the
committees up there
first we'll look at well the wallets the
money ways and means will once again be
chaired by maggie carlton
with daniel monroe moreno as the vice
chair
the revenue committee will be chaired by
leslie cohen and teresa benitez thompson
is the vice chair
with police reform on the agenda the
judiciary committee could have some of
the key
bills going through there and it'll be
headed once again by steve yeager
rochelle nguyen will serve as the vice
chair education
always a top subject in carson city and
that committee will be headed by shannon
bilbray axelrod
brittany miller is the vice chair
bilbray axelrod is
new to the education committee we'll
have the latest on the legislative
session moving forward have a good rest
of your weekend